good evening everyone I'm melody Curtis
with the Smithsonian associates and I
want to thank you for coming to our
program this evening it's my pleasure on
behalf of the Smithsonian to welcome you
tonight and to introduce our speaker
renowned author Joseph Stiglitz who will
discuss his new book globalization and
its discontents you may have noticed
that the book is available directly
outside the lecture hall and dr.
Stiglitz will sign copies immediately
following the program tonight dr. Joseph
Stiglitz holds a chaired joint
professorship at Columbia University in
the Graduate School of Business the
Economics Department and the School of
International and public affairs from
1997 through 2000 the World Bank's
senior vice president for development
economics and his chief economist from
1993 through 97 he served as a member
and then chairman of President Clinton's
Council of Economic Advisors and as a
member of the president's cabinet and in
2001 dr. Stiglitz shared the Nobel Prize
in Economics science for analyses of
markets with asymmetric information
please join me in welcoming dr. Joseph
Stiglitz
well it's a pleasure to be here the
subject of globalization has received an
enormous amount of interest in the last
few years actually in the amount of
interesting in Europe and and the rest
of the world is is even greater than
that in the United States
there are two very contrasting views of
globalization one one view sees
globalization is the best thing since
sliced bread eggs if supposed to bring
unprecedented prosperity to all the
countries of the world in that
particular perspective it's very hard to
understand why there is being such
discontent with globalization
particularly in the developing countries
if it were the case that globalization
was making them so much better off
question is why why don't they seem to
recognize this and if if you took that
perspective the each the person writing
this book should not be an economist but
as a psychologist or a social
psychologist to try to understand why it
is that they haven't understood that
they're supposed to be happy well I
there's the other view which which says
that globalization has has has brought
unmitigated disaster to many many of the
countries developing countries and that
view I think also underestimates the
benefits which have come from
globalization globalization is used
usually to refer to the closer
integration of the countries and peoples
of the world as a result of the lowering
of transportation costs lowering of
communication costs and the reduction of
artificial barriers but more is X taken
globalization than just the flow of
goods and services the
the flow of capital it also involves
flows of knowledge and inflows of
knowledge have had enormous benefit the
just mentioned one one particular area
that the the increased access to health
technology has increased living
standards lifespans enormous lis in many
of the developing countries in many of
the countries particularly in East Asia
the gap the knowledge gap between the
those countries the more developed
countries as narrowed enormous lis and
we now recognize that what has what one
of the causes of lack of development is
not only lack of resources the lack of
access to knowledge so so this aspect of
globalization has brought enormous
benefits another aspect of globalization
that has brought enormous benefits it is
the globalization of civil society in
fact the globalization movement itself
the protest movement is itself a
manifestation of globalization and the
global globalized civil society is
having some very impressive successes
the landmines treaty which which tried
to restrict the use of Lang's mine was
succeeded over the opposition of the US
Defense Department the Jubilee 2000
movement which was very strong in Europe
succeeded in getting debt relief for
over 20 countries in the year 2000
after years of in which the IMF have
been foot-dragging and only three or
four countries had succeeded in getting
debt relief essentially the IMF exit
standards that almost no country could
could reach if they could reach that
they wouldn't be under underdeveloped
and the
the the Jubilee mm movement said look at
you know there's a really moral
responsibility here to to give debt
relief and it put enough pressure on the
advanced industrial countries that debt
relief was given to 20 additional
countries so they've been I think these
very major successes on the part of
globalization there's one other very
important set of successes and that is
the countries of East Asia China Korea
other countries of East Asia which over
the last 35 years have grown enormously
and have reduced poverty enormous Lee
just to give you some numbers in Korea
per capita income over a period of 30
years increased Eightfold it was a you
know a success in development that I
think few people fifty years ago could
even end have anticipated and the core
basis of their success in East Asia was
exports was export led growth and
exports meant that they were taking
advantage of globalization they were
taking advantage of the new
opportunities that global marketplaces
afforded and they were bringing in
technology from the more advanced
industrial countries but what
distinguished East Asia from much much
of the rest of the world is that in East
Asia the countries of East Asia really
to charge a globalization themselves
they they made globalization work for
their own country they adapted it to
their own circumstances in contrast in
much of the rest of the world the
process of globalization has been pushed
run determined by the international
financial institutions one of the things
that distinguished the policies that
East Asia used and the policies that
were used in much they also the world
is the balanced perspective that East
Asia took to the role of government
government took a very active role in
promoting development and promoting
globalization and in protecting the the
people in the country from from some of
the the undesirable consequences that
contrast to a very strong free-market
ideology which which dominated
particularly in the in the period of the
80s in the in the Reagan Thatcher ID
period but has continued to dominate
even even later at some of the
international financial institutions and
and so much of the objection to
globalization is not - globalization per
se but to the particular ways that
globalization has been managed that it's
been managed in ways in which there has
been this overlay a free-market ideology
which has meant that it has not been
able to be managed well and as a result
there there have been very adverse
effects on poverty and and even adverse
effects on economic growth the
there are other issues that have been
raised in the globalization debate some
of which I'll have which I get into the
book I'll just be able to mention very
briefly tonight one of them is that one
of the most important is that
globalization has been managed by the
international economic institutions with
rules that have been set by the more
advanced industrial countries for
themselves or more particularly for
special interests within the more
advanced industrial countries and with
the less developed countries often
disadvantaged let me just give you one
one example of that the ORAC way round
which is the last round of trade
negotiations was widely held in the
United States is a very major victory
for the Clinton administration and it
was also held in Europe we talked about
how many jobs were being created - how
much income would rise but wasn't talked
about was the fact that it was a very
unfair trade agreement United States and
Europe insisted on Africa and the less
developed countries opening up their
markets to the goods produced by the
advanced industrial countries they
insisted on the less developed countries
eliminating their subsidies and at the
same time the United States and Europe
and and and Japan kept their markets
closed relatively close to the goods
that were the natural comparative
advantage of the less developed
countries the goods that they bless
developed countries could export so for
instance textiles were restricted their
quotas were were kept on that for
another ten years
agricultural goods continued to be
subsidized in the United States and
Europe and the problem hasn't been come
any better the United States just
recently passed a farm bill which
increased the level of subsidies - to
even higher levels and introduced
subsidies for new products
and that of course sex a pattern in
which group respected the developing
countries there's this enormous
hypocrisy and this enormous inequity in
fact after their work around the World
Bank we did some calculations which
showed that the poorest region of the
world sub-saharan Africa was actually
worse off their incomes went down by
about two percent as a result it was
called the terms of trade effects and
it's because of that that that's just
you know one of several examples of how
it is that the rules of the game are
being set in ways which disadvantage the
less developed countries the good news
is that some of these problems are are
at last being being recognized and the
next round of trade negotiations that
was initiated in Doha in November of
last year has been called the
development round because it's been
recognized that if there's going to be
any any progress in this direction there
has to be a redressing of the imbalances
of previous trade around trade
agreements well I want to spend a few
minutes more describing some of the
failures of globalization and a few
stories that will highlight the bring
out some of the examples of where of why
things why they're sexually discontent
with globalization in the book I talk
focused around three particular issues
about around the issue of development
the process of bringing the poorest
countries in Africa narrowing the income
gaps between them in the rest of the
world the problems of crisis management
the kinds of crisis we saw in East Asia
that we've seen now in Latin America and
are the problem of transition the
transition of the former communist
countries such as Russia into a market
economy and in each of these areas there
has been I would argue and
failures beginning with a problem with
development the the 90s marked a race
between an increase in income and an
increase in population such that the
well it turned out that the percentage
of people in poverty went down the
absolute number of people in poverty
actually went up the number of people
and when we are talking about poverty
we're talking about numbers like one
dollar a day and these are really
extreme levels of poverty one of the
episodes I described in the book was was
one of my first experiences after coming
to the World Bank I went to Ethiopia
which is in fact one of the poorest
countries in the world and they had had
a one of the most one of the worst
political regimes that the world has
experienced it was the magista regime
who actually used the term red terror
they would kill people and lead them in
the streets in order to keep they called
discipline and melis that army that
gorillas that that overthrew the magista
regime and this was a 91 and since then
have been maintaining normally
successful economic policies the country
was growing at 5% inflation was brought
down to zero and the government had a
balanced budget I went to Ethiopia and
they were having a major dispute with
the IMF and I couldn't understand why
after all the IMF is supposed to focus
on macroeconomic policy and
macroeconomic policy it should have been
given an A+ and the question is what was
the dispute about well it turned out
that there were a number of items that
in dispute but one of them was that the
IMF claimed that they weren't having the
budget wasn't in balance now you thought
among green eyeshade accountants people
looking at the numbers either it wasn't
balanced or was and I thought it was
imbalanced how could we disagree people
you know to look at the numbers and
either was was or was not imbalanced
well the IMF argument was that well the
numbers looked okay but they they they
were relying on foreign aid and if you
excluded foreign aid they would be out
of balance
it's the OPA city I said yes I mean
that's why we've been trying to get four
and eight and the IMF said well what
happens if if the foreign aid stops you
can't rely on it it's too unstable no
less who actually had at while he was
was fighting the guerrilla war had
studied economics because he knew the
key problem for his country was was
going to be an economics problem was
going to be economics and was very weird
budgetary situation I mean he actually
even though he come it came into power
through military meetings he cut his
military expenditures back from 6% to 2%
of GDP
because he knew every dollar he spent on
defense was taking money away from from
rural development which he saw as the
sort of key okay he said well you know
there's an obvious answer we're not
engaged in a Star Wars program that's
going to take twenty years we're
building schools that take three months
to construct six months to construct and
if we get the money we'll build the
schools we'll build the health clinics
if we don't get the money we'll stop
building them this is not you know we
don't need a tenure investment program
we will have flexible expenditure when
the money stops we stop spending it we
went back to to Washington and did some
calculations
we show that it turned out that tax
revenues were more unstable than foreign
aid so if you use the IMF logic you
shouldn't include foreign aid and you
shouldn't include tax revenue but of
course if you don't include foreign aid
and tax revenue every country in the
world is in bad budget because you've
actually limited all the revenues and
then in a very emotional statement melis
you know said to me he said you know he
hadn't fought for 17 years new gorillas
to be told by some bureaucrat from
international bureaucrat that he
couldn't build schools for his people
that he couldn't build health come on
experienced people if he could succeed
in persuading UK government or the
Swedish government to give that money
they were giving the money in order to
have these schools built they weren't
giving money just they had to go into
reserves which is what the IMF wanted
the money to go for in any case that was
just one example of the kinds of
problems the kinds of issues where we're
as a result of that people say
something's wrong with with with
globalization the in that particular
case we succeeded I succeeded in getting
the World Bank they looked at the
numbers and they said Ethiopia is
actually having very good economic
policies and they tripled their lending
while the IMF Haddix program suspended
now in general that's very difficult and
very unusual because normally when the
IMF suspends its program the World Bank
and other bilateral donors also suspend
their program which is why it gives the
IMF such leverage its not only the IMF
money that's at stake but all the other
donors money is at stake as well looking
at it more broadly in the context of
development the the great success
allegedly of the reform programs
he was sometimes called the Washington
Consensus policies was latin america and
we now have a decade of data available
for latin america under reform and
globalization and the numbers have come
out quite striking growth during the
past decade in latin america has been
just over half of what it was in the 50s
60s and 70s before reform and so all
over latin america the question is being
asked why his reform what is what has
happened reform globalization
how will they failed us and it's even
worse than I've just described because
the countries that have succeeded in
growth the benefits have not been
widespread take Mexico which they
succeed partly because of the close
relations with the United States most of
the benefits of growth there have gone
to the upper ten and upper 30% most of
that to the upper 10% the people at the
bottom many of the people at the bottom
are actually worse off so for them the
fact that there are some people at the
upper end are doing very well doesn't
make them feel any better and and that
is a picture that you see throughout
Latin America it's a picture which which
the recent contrast between what has
we've gone on United States and what's
going on in Latin America in
particularly IMF policies has has
generated more concern about United
States
remember went through a recession in the
year 2001 in which both sides both
Democrats and Republicans agreed that it
was important to have stimulatory fiscal
policy everybody agreed that we ought to
have expansionary fiscal policy to get
us out of the recession there was a
disagreement about the best way of
designing the policy of whether in fact
one side or the others really did have
an effective stimulus policy but the
notion that you ought to stimulate an
economy in a recession was agreed by
almost everybody enya in latin america
as in much of the rest of the
old the IMF has taken exactly the
opposite position in Argentina it
insisted on a halving contractionary
fiscal policy and that converted a
downturn into a deeper recession a
recession into a depression exactly the
same mistake that occurred in East Asia
a few years before as an economist these
are quite interesting experiments
because they verify our theories our
theories say that when you having a
recession if you cut back on
expenditures increase taxes the
recession gets worse
and we keep having these experiments
that show that our theories are right
and a scientist that's very nice but for
the people involved in the countries
it's not the greatest thing the let me
turn to the broader issue of of economic
stability the world over the last 30
years has experienced a large number of
crises in fact almost 100 countries have
had crises it's more unusual not to have
a crisis if you're a developing country
than to have one the policies that the
IMF pursued capital market push on these
countries capital market liberalization
which is subjecting the country to this
short-term spective money that can come
in and out of the country overnight has
been identified as one of the primary
sources of this kind of instability when
fickle capital markets decide they don't
like a country they pull their money out
and that can have devastating effects
particularly on developing countries
even before capital market
liberalisation was pushed by the IMF
there was an enormous amount in he stay
even before the East Asia crisis there
was an enormous amount of evidence that
this capital market liberalisation was a
source a major source of ink apple
market liberalization does not lead to
faster economic growth there's a
considerable body of evidence that the
actually provides a theory and evidence
that that points this out let me just
give you one aspect of that to help
bring it bring it bring out the point
more more forcefully today in general
argue that when countries borrow abroad
short-term in foreign denominated
currency in order for there to maintain
Prudential positions they have to
maintain reserves equal to the amounts
that they borrowed so if a twork African
country borrows a hundred million
dollars from an American bank it is
considered to be prudent policy on the
part of the country to put a hundred
million dollars into reserves
these are money that that the current
country has in case the American Bank
decides it wants those dollars back the
country then has the dollars to pay back
okay now how do countries typically hold
their reserves the way they hold their
reserves is not just not in general
dollars but they actually hold US
Treasury bills now let's think through
what that implies this country this poor
countries borrowed a hundred million
dollars from the United States from an
American bank and is probably paying 18%
interest it's a high interest rate
because it represents the risk that
these countries face eighteen or twenty
percent but the country is at the same
time lending to the United States when
you buy a US Treasury bill you are
lending to the American government so
this African country is lending to the
United States right now what is the pain
what is the United what is it what is it
getting back from the United States what
interest rate does it receive from the
United States around three percent so
it's borrowing at eighteen percent and
lending at three percent now that's not
good economics and it's very hard for
you to grow now it is good for the
United States and the US Treasury loves
this and and in that sense we should
it's part of our Africa's foreign aid
program for the United States and we
should be thankful for it but but you
cannot argue that this is a policy that
encourages economic growth in developing
countries which is why capital market
liberalization has not been associated
with faster economic growth there's some
other arguments that that that are
associated with this but this because
you were a basic picture the transition
from communism to a market economy could
hardly have been managed worse think
about what we said about the communist
economic system we said was a terrible
economic system and it was central
planning no government could ever have
the amount of information required to
make an economy work they had no
incentives they had no private property
they had enormous amount of distortions
what was the market economy supposed to
do a market economy was supposed to have
decentralization so you have information
dispersed throughout the economy you
have private is that you have profit
motives and private property giving
incentives you have liberalisation
eliminating the distortion and all of
this was supposed to increase incomes
what actually happened in Russia incomes
went down thirty to forty percent it
wasn't just a temporary transition
recession lasted a year or two even
today
the income in Russia is 25 35 percent
below where it was at the beginning of
the transition poverty increased from
around 2% to in 1998 over 40 percent an
enormous increase in poverty and these
numbers are corroborated by looking at
you know the numbers I don't want to
give you a picture that it's hard to get
accurate numbers but there are a number
of different ways where we can get the
numbers we do household living standards
we can look at life expectancy while on
the rest of the world life expectancy
increased by a year or two in Russia
life expectancy felt enormous Lee the
problem is that there is a clear
connection between the policies that
were pushed and these outcomes just as
there was in the case of the crises just
as there has been in the case of
development take one only one one issue
one of the things that the IMF pushed
was that these countries should
privatize as rapidly as possible didn't
matter how you privatize but turn it
over to the private sector by the way
it's not very difficult to privatize you
just give away the stakes asacs to your
friends the the program in Russia was
not much short of that but there was a
combination of policies that in some
ways made it even worse because the
rapid privatization was viewed as a very
illegitimate privatization because you
had this country where there was not
even enough money to pay pensioners
there 10 or 15 dollars a month but you
meanwhile you were giving billions of
dollars away to a few friends of Yeltsin
and so the privatization was viewed as
not really being legitimate but at the
same time you combine that
with capital market liberalization where
you effectively said take your money and
invest it anywhere in the world that you
want and you ask yourself if you're
smart enough to figure out how to get
yokes and to give you a few billion
dollars would you rather leave your
money in Russia which was in a
depression in which you knew that there
be another government and that next
government might not be quite so
favorable to letting you keep your
proceeds from this illegitimate
privatization or would you rather take
your money out put it in United States
which was having a boom put in secret
bank accounts in Cyprus or in
Switzerland if there's another
government they can't take the money
back again you're safe and the answer
was very clear
well the IMF was lending billions into
Russia the oligarchs taking the money
the proceeds from privatization we're
taking out dozens of billions of dollars
out of the country and as a result of
that it's not surprising that Russia
went into a deep recession from which it
is just beginning to emerge well as I
say the book details these failures and
development and transition in crisis and
it tries to do what I try to do is look
for some common themes these are not
just random mistakes there's a pattern
and what I try to do is look for that
common pattern the deeper question is
why why were these mistakes made now let
me say as an economist I do not believe
it was because of mistakes of economic
science economists knew that if you have
a country facing recession you don't
impose contractionary fiscal and
monetary policies that just makes the
downturn worse that's been the basis of
economics for the last 70 years
narsings Herbert Hoover have people
advocated the kind of
seas that were commonplace at the IMF in
the East Asia crisis
similarly economic science pointed out
the risks associated with capital market
liberalisation and that it was risk
without reward that there wasn't
evidence or theory that would promote
economic growth in fact the evidence was
to the contrary the it's also the case
that that there were many bright people
at these institutions some have been my
students although I don't think they
always listened as carefully as they
should have the problems of imperfect
markets had been the subject of research
had been in fact one of the focal points
for economic research for the past
quarter century the work that for which
I got that was mentioned introduction
freaka the Nobel Prize was done in the
early 70s and this were focusing on him
focused on imperfection imperfect
information and imperfect markets well
developing countries imperfections of
information imperfections to market
characterized these economies they're
there at the core of the problems of
these economies and one of the results
that that I emphasized in my research
was that when markets when information
is imperfect when markets are incomplete
markets often do not reveal the kinds of
results that one would like one of the
most important results in economics is
called the invisible hand theorem Adam
Smith's argument that market economies
lead as if by invisible hand to
efficient outcomes very very powerful
idea and what what this research over
the last 25 years has shown is that one
of the reasons that Adam Smith's
invisible hand made
invisible is that it's not there and
that there is an important role for
government and if you look at all the
successful cases the United States East
Asia government has played a very
important role in the development
strategies at critical junctures so the
question is to come again why why have
there been these failures why other than
these pervasive failures why have have
the IMF the WTO pursue these policies
which seem so so to make so little sense
seem to have failed so so pervasively
and I try to argue that in fact it's a
combination of ideology and interest
it's not what do you call naked
self-interest one of the things I saw
repeatedly when I was at the Council of
Economic Advisers is that no one argues
for naked self-interest
no one says the reason you should give
us subsidies is because well you know
it'd be nice for us that's not an
argument you ever hear what you always
hear is the reason we you know you ought
to give us subsidies is that we are
vital to the country and to the world's
welfare so everybody always couches the
arguments in terms of general interest
and what if it happens unfortunately is
a lot of people actually come to believe
their arguments they are so persuaded by
them that they actually so that they
don't actually believe that they are
pursuing self-interest they really
believe that they're pursuing general
interest so take the issue of capital
market liberalisation that was an issue
that uh was felt you know by people who
believe in free markets they said we
don't have to see the evidence we know
that free markets are good and any
evidence that you show that they might
not have led to that they might have led
to greater risk or there might not have
led to greater growth
can't be right because we know the
answer
free markets are better than then unfree
markets and you say well what about the
S&L tobacco in the United States where
we deregulated and we wound up the
taxpayers wound up paying a several
hundred billion dollar bill and
sometimes like joke well the United
States won to share that experience
around the world how'd everybody have
that that kind of experience but the the
point I want to emphasize is that that
ideology often works very closely in
line with with interests so that it's
not a surprise that the people who felt
most strongly about free capital markets
were those who happen also to have an
interest in free capital markets who
were the people who were placing selling
investing or making money out of
investments in in the newly opened up
markets for them this was another
opening up market opportunities just as
we were trying to open up markets to
American goods around the world this was
just a particular good was our capital
and we were trying to open up markets to
our capital so there was a a confluence
there between interest and and ideology
and is also you know what one of the
things I try to do in the book is to try
to highlight how how if you how bet how
many things aspects of the policies that
say of the IMF makes so little sense
when you look at them from a
dispassionate point of view they almost
look inconsistent let me tell you what
give you some examples
the IMF believes very strongly believe
very strongly in the free-market
ideology and in this in in markets over
government but if you think about it for
a minute they are a public institution
they are a public institution founded by
the governments of the world now their
general view is governments don't work
very well and you ought to rely on
markets because governments fail but
they never turn the the gays back on
themselves say we're a public
institution we fail to that's not a view
that they took very lightly to the the
particularly a SPECT of this is that as
part of the one of the things that I saw
repeatedly when I was at the White House
was that everybody believed in two
general principals one of them was there
should be no subsidies for anybody
except ourselves
and the other one is there should be
competition in every industry except our
own and these principles
I saw applied to the IMF for instance
you talked about free markets but what
was the IMF doing what were the policies
that it was pursuing particularly in the
period that we're talking about in this
book it was having these multi-billion
dollar bailouts when I talk about
spending money we're talking about big
time money and it sometimes you know
this expression petty wise and pound
foolish
well did I say something wrong
okay Oh makes me nervous here anyway the
the you're focusing on spending they're
worried about a few food subsidies fuel
subsidies costing a few millions of
dollars but with the size of the
bailouts
all told East Asia they were there they
were over a hundred billion dollars in
Brazil there was fifty billion dollars
money that was spent not with any
congressional appropriation in fact in
the case of Mexico Congress rejected the
bailout so what we see here is these
enormous amounts of money but where were
the money going it was that intervention
in the market so the IMF said we want to
intervene in this market but not in
other markets you ask well what was the
principle here well if you start looking
at it in terms of ideology and interest
you see a principle but it was one
that's hard to defend let me give you
another example they very much as I said
before pushed for a capital market
liberalization but what was the argument
that they often put for a bailout they
worried about contagion that a problem
in one country would lead to a problem
another well the problem of contagion in
economic term means is like a disease
it's like an externality of what goes on
in one country will have effects on
others whenever you have an externality
there is a role for government
intervention before the disease you want
to prevent the diseases in the first
place but what was the cause of the
instability it was this specular capital
movements so if that's the cause of the
problem and you recognize the problem
can go from one country to another why
not try to address the original problem
which was this high highly speculative
capital flows but they said no we can't
touch that that's
three markets so you have if you look at
detail of what they did it was a pattern
that had no intellectual clearings to it
and and that I think by looking at that
you get a picture of looking at the
patterns you get a picture of the
combination of ideology and interest and
you see why it was an economic science
that was underlying these policies well
the last part of the book I try to to to
address the question what can be be done
about these problems in a way what I one
of the things as economists that I
believe and I believe this is that
incentives matter and so if you want to
know why did why did Russia fail it was
because the wrong set of incentives were
put into place similarly if you ask look
at an organization like the IMF or like
any other organization look at the
incentives that are provided by the
governing structure the political
structure in which they're embedded
well think about who runs the IMF who
makes the decisions well there are two
problems one of them is the voting
rights are disproportionately in the
hands of the advanced industrial
countries there's been a lot of
complaints about the UN with only five
countries having the veto power and it's
a lot of historical anachronism in their
people one of the European countries
that has the veto power has a lower GDP
than many other countries in the world
and has a much lower population than
many other countries of the world but it
happens to have been one of the
victorious powers in world war two so
now more than 50 years after the end of
World War two it still has the veto
power in the IMF only one country has
the veto power as you know there's a
meeting
beginning in in Kanna called the g8 or
g7 well it's the g1 that has the veto
power in in the IMF and then you ask the
question who represents the United
States or each of the other countries in
the IMF and the representation is
designed to give a wide spectrum of
views there are two governors of the of
the IMF from each country the finance
minister and the central bank governors
so you get a whole spectrum of views
within the financial community the in
the United States when and this is true
in both Democratic and Republican
administrations when we come to make
economic decisions we have something
called the National Economic Council in
which everybody who is a stakeholder six
around the table it's not just Treasury
we know what Treasury's views on a lot
of issues would be and they often are
different from that of a lot of other
people they have a lot of wisdom they
know what the markets are but they also
have a lot of interests and so we have
labor we have this Council of Economic
Advisers which is supposed to look at
the overall economic framework we have
Department of Justice's in there because
antitrust issues often arise we have
commerce we have trade everybody sits
around the table we have environment
because economic issues often have
environmental impacts the IMF is not
just concerned with details of oh you
know is IMF we're just concerned about
better mechanisms for clearing checks
there would be no controversy but that's
not what the IMF is involved in it's
involved in dictating economic policies
that have enormous impacts on countries
around the world in the developing
countries around the world
and yet only a limited number of voices
are heard
it is not representative the people who
who were thrown out of work in East Asia
because of the excessively can
action airy fiscal policies those
workers had no voice the small
businesses that were forced into
bankruptcy when interest rates were
raised to twenty thirty forty fifty
percent had no voice and that is in some
sense the fundamental problem the
fundamental problem with the
international economic institutions and
that's what really needs to be changed
unfortunately I don't think it's going
to happen very quickly the in spite of a
recognition that this is the fundamental
problem there's not been a race to give
up the veto or a race to turn over more
voting power to two developing countries
and that's why in the book I try to talk
about some intermediate solutions things
that would make a difference a
difference for the positive but but in
some things don't get at the fundamental
problem one of these is increasing
transparency and accountability
particularly because these institutions
are not directly democratically
accountable it's very important to make
it more transparent what is going on by
making a more transparent other voices
can be heard if not at the voting at
least through the new media through
through the newspapers through a variety
of other channels unfortunately while
they should be more transparent they're
actually less transparent we've come in
the United States to value the Freedom
of Information Act the accept as a basic
principle the right to know the citizens
have the right to know but you have no
right to know how your representative if
the IMF has voted Congress does not even
have the right to know how that
representative votes
there is a lack of transparency which
which those of us who believe in
democratic principles find in that in
some sense appalling there there are up
ways of increasing Moran's parents they
should be increased I think the the
accountability should be increased for
instance before the IMF goes into a
country with a program it should lay out
it should lay out what is going to be
impact on unemployment on poverty and
then after the program outsiders should
come in and evaluate whether their
forecasts of what they said was going to
happen actually occurred and if they're
systematically not telling us what's
going to happen then something a lot of
change to give you another example in
Western Europe many countries there has
been a la there's been a lot of pressure
on governments to release the economic
models by which they make their
forecasts but those models are still not
publicly available in the case of the
IMF and without those models it's
difficult to judge are they under
estimating or over estimating why is it
that they systematically seem to make so
many mistakes
the third set of reforms have to do with
specific measures specific policies and
I want to put this in a much broader
thing it's not just in the financial
area but it's in trade and other areas I
talked in the beginning about how the
trade agenda in the past has been very
imbalanced for instance to give you just
one more example in the won one of the
great achievements that people talked
about in in their work around was
extending trade globalization to
services from goods it has used to be
focused just on goods like steel and
things like that
extending it to services but what was
the service that was extended to
financial services the services that the
developing countries care about
construction services maritime services
they weren't on the agenda and so that's
one of the reasons why why in the new
trade round there has to be greater
equity a greater sense of redressing the
imbalance so that's I think just of one
of the most important issues that that
that has to be addressed if we're going
to make globalization work better
there are particularly issues within
that that I don't have time to talk
about intellectual property that I
talked about very briefly in the book
but those also have to be corrected in
the area of global financial
institutions the IMF my view is that
that the kinds of policies the excessive
contractionary policies are a mistake I
also argue that the big bailouts are a
mistake
they didn't work and the good news is
that changes is already in process after
the failures of the big bailouts in
Thailand Indonesia Korea Russia Brazil
and finally Argentina the message got
across
after a hundreds of billion dollars were
spent they said well maybe this isn't
working so well and they are now
proposing what I argued very strongly
should have been the policy in the East
Asia crisis and others argued was should
have been the policy even earlier and
that is a greater reliance on bankruptcy
standstills workouts ways of resolving
you know problems that that make the
lender bear more the cost in the 19th
century
when when debtors couldn't pay their
that what was owed in Britain they were
thrown into debtor prisons and when
countries couldn't pay what was owed ma
when when Mexico couldn't pay what was
owed in the middle of the 19th century
the British and French armies moved in
now today we think of that not quite as
politically correct but there has been a
reluctance to face up to what ought to
be done which is it is more efficient
almost every developed country has
bankruptcy proceedings within their own
country and what we now need to have is
those proceedings to to grow a
cross-border for sovereign debt and for
decks that go from one country to
another well what I hope I try to do in
these brief remarks is to lay out a
framework to show why it is that there
is such discontent with globalization
that the complaints that many of those
who have been discontent with
globalization complains that it has not
worked for the poor that it's unfair
that it has undermined democracy that
there's a lot of legitimacy to those
complaints but then on the other hand
globalization can be a very powerful
positive force but if it's to be that
positive force there have to be basic
changes in the way globalization is
managed and that means changes in the
way the international economic
institutions which have such an
important role in managing these the
process of globalization the way they
behave and emotionally in the way they
are governed this too has to be changed
if these changes are done then I am
optimistic that in fact globalization
can be become live up to the positive
potential that it could be thanks
now there's a there's a opportunity for
some questions yeah what do you see in
role hooping
enforcer let me first try to distinguish
between the bank and the fund they have
two very different mandates the the
bank's mandate is reducing poverty and
promoting economic growth in developing
countries the fund has seen its men its
mandate is global economic stability now
not only do they have different mandates
they have a very different cultures one
is very hierarchical in structure one is
much more decentralized the bank has a
lot of people out in the field and one
of the problem one of the one of the
advantages of being out in the field is
you really do come to understand the
country a lot better I talked about the
the narrow vision that the IMF has
because it focuses mainly on financial
markets because the World Bank works in
education environment health it's
talking to those ministers those
departments those aspects of society all
the time and inevitably it lines up with
a broader vision now there was a period
particularly in the 80s when the World
Bank worked very closely in concert with
IMF on what I call structural adjustment
loans where the IMF would lay down the
austerity measures and the World Bank
would help implement them and that was a
particular problem in the economies in
transition and so a lot of the the
criticism where the two organizations
are bundled together dates to that
period of structural adjustment loans
where were you know the problem was they
were very much sister institutions but
as I gave an example in Ethiopia that
was a case where the fun stopped the
lending the bank couldn't do any
structural adjustment lending couldn't
do any broad-based lending but could go
ahead with education projects and health
projects and so forth
the bank has made enormous amount of
reform over the last six years it has
is reformed both the rhetoric and to a
large extent the reality for instance
it's moved much more trying to move away
from conditionality which says we will
give you money only if you do these
things to what's called selectivity you
show that you're managing your economy
we'll we'll give you money you write and
though they even use words like the
country should be in the driver's seat
and they there and you know the bank
because it's decentralized what goes on
in one area may be quite different from
another several the country's several
the you know places where the bank has
programs this is not only a rhetoric but
really I've got you seen it as a reality
the the fund has been much slower in in
making these kinds of reforms though as
I say there are changes occurring today
for instance the movement towards
recognition of the role of bankruptcy
and the weaknesses the bailout is
something that finally is is coming
about
that is the thought that evocative wires
kind of equal knowledge of both parties
what if the my system to give us the
right kind of signals to make everything
efficient and from your description it
seems that the IMF which is yelling at
our free-market ideology it's kind of
the evenings which is total violation of
those assumptions I needed to make it
work eating open information and little
barracks
I was putting comment and maybe becoming
what I remember that's wrong or okay the
question is standard economic theory
talks about the importance of having
good information to make markets work
and yet the way the IMF often operates
is with lack of transparency which
basically reduces the quality of
information and doesn't that seem to go
against the basic principles of what
makes markets work that's an interesting
question and and it goes to the whole
general issue of the culture of secrecy
versus openness and to me this was one
of the difficult things for me to get
used to because I came from academia
where the general principle is that you
ought to have open discussions and you
ought to you know everything is open and
that's the way knowledge progresses
that's not the culture that was in the
IMF nor is that the culture that's in
the financial markets financial markets
make money out of secrecy and one of the
problems is this link between the IMF
and the financial markets I think they
borrow a lot of the culture from the
financial markets so to give you one
example where this plays out not only at
the international level but domestically
central banks traditionally have been
very secretive and have not been very
open about what they do
argument has been put is that if you had
openness it would destabilize the
markets now that argument has been put
without any evidence and you would have
thought that since there are so many
people trying to guess what the Fed or
what the central bank of England is
going to do or some other central that
has to be unproductive economic activity
all these people are trying to figure
out something that somebody else already
knows and and it's sort of a game one of
the interesting things is that the UK
about five years ago began a policy of
more transparency more openness they
actually record the votes that people
make on their their central bank Oh
raising interest rates lowering interest
rates it has not had any adverse effect
on instability and it shows that the
markets can have worked much I believe
much better with more openness and more
transparency and this is just not a code
view it as a cultural aspect you know
they're they're very proud now that so
much is up on the web so that they view
that as a success and track sparing safe
I don't view that I think it's a right
step forward having more things posted
but but what we really need is they have
a you know the the premise ought to be
what we have is the premise the United
States which is there's a citizen's
right to know everything should be
public except for clearly delineated
exceptions like National Defense where
you can say there is some harm that can
be done some privacy exceptions from
from from revealing some information
think about the connection between the
environmental changes that are going on
in the in globalization should there be
a strong connection somehow and this be
of course international
to help globalization take some look at
what's happening in the environment some
standards that might be applied
well the let me put the question was for
those who didn't hear is is is the
broader issue of globalization in the
environment and the when I talked about
before about globalization I should have
I should have expanded the discussion
and talked about a concept that's become
very widely used in the last couple
years and that's called global public
goods or global externalities where
where there are some where we're used to
thinking of things that need to be
provided at the national level or at the
local level like we have there are
certain things like like police and fire
protection that we think of as local
public goods that are provided by the
local community there are things that
are need to be provided at the national
level
well increasingly as the world has
become more integrated the global level
there are things that have to be
provided at a global level and one of
the important global issues are global
environmental issues including global
warming the atmosphere we all share the
same atmosphere if you with what you
know if the United States puts more co2
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere its
affects people in China India everywhere
in the world and and has enormous
impacts everywhere and that is an aspect
of globalization that has not gotten
sufficient attention now where it
actually interacts very importantly with
the global economic issues that I've
been focusing on is in trade policy
because one of the one of the key
questions is how if there is what I say
a rogue state a government that refuses
that continues to pollute and it in
spite of the fact that everybody else
has said you know we have to stop the
pollution
how do you put pressure on the next day
to stop polluting well there aren't many
mechanisms today I mean we aren't going
to send in an army to take over the
country or anything like that one of the
few instruments we have is trade policy
in the case of the of the
ozone-depleting chemicals there was a
convention called the Montreal
Convention that restricted the emission
of these chemicals that were you know
related to air conditioners that put the
holes in the ozone that have the effect
of giving you cancer of the skin and and
with that was a very successful
international agreement in the
environment but one of the provisions of
that was that any country that didn't go
along there was an agreement that there
could put trade sanctions against that
country now there is a great deal of
worry about whether under the WTO
whether trade Trump's environment
whether you can impose whether you can
impose trade sanctions for being bad
environmentally it's an issue that's not
clear there was a recent decision by a
WTO panel in the shrimp turtle case this
is this was a case where where the the
we're actually United States was on the
the right side on this particular case
that the there was a a the question was
if you fish for shrimp with certain
kinds of necks you catch turtles and
kill the turtles which a lot of people
don't think is a bad thing okay
especially scarcity rare Turtles so
there was a provision that said that you
had to use turtle friendly Nets under
WTO rules
you cannot insist on a particular
process for production in other words if
if you employ Turtles if you import
shrimp you can't care about how the
shrimp get get caught but the WTO panel
said that in this case there was an
interest in preserving the environment
and that this was a legitimate
restriction but this is only one case
there were other cases that people did
not think it was going to go that way so
the issue is if a country for instance
produces aluminum using highly polluting
environmental mechanisms you know
coal that pollutes the environment can
other countries say we don't want that
aluminum or put a special tariff on that
aluminum saying that that's not good for
the global environment we don't know the
answer to that that kind of case has not
been brought but it is something which I
think a lot of people who concern about
the environment say that there shouldn't
be any ambiguity about that we should
have the right other country should have
the right to impose to impose tariffs to
protect the global environment yeah
develop
and I was just wondering what
well I think the the private sector can
play a very important role in
development the government needs to play
it has an important role too to to
provide an environment that is
attractive to the private sector but
there was a lot of enthusiasm about the
private sector prior to the 97-98 global
financial crisis flows of private
capital increased six-fold from 1990 to
1996 and so people say well you know
this that they were much larger than the
public capital flows but most the
capital was going to a relatively few
countries about 12 countries and most of
the capital was going to a limited
number of sectors wasn't going to
education wasn't going to help and these
are obviously very important
prerequisites for successful development
it is important as I say for governments
to try to create the environment which
is attractive for private investment and
part of that environment and will
include investments in education and
health but right now we have to
recognize that the private sector has
been reluctant to go into some countries
even after they've pursued relatively
good economic policies for an extended
period of time several the African
countries now have had almost a decade
of good economic policies and they have
not been able to attract foreign direct
investment now it may be possible if we
open up our markets they have trade
liberalization at the United States
opens up its markets you're open
Suffolk's markets that investment will
come to these particular countries so
and there's some evidence some evidence
concerning that
so in short I do think that the private
sector has an important role but we
tried we we in the West have an
important role to try to make it more
attractive for the private sector to
come in yeah yeah well if the private
sector does become a larger role and
maybe micro lender is more active and
those kinds of things
you said that the IMF is lacks
transparency
is not democratic it's lack scalability
what anarchists in favor of this
continues well the basic point is that
globalization has led to the closer
integration of the countries of the
world we're more interdependent and just
as 150 years ago as national economies
formed and there's greater
interdependence within the United States
and within the European countries there
was a need for a larger role for the
national government you see all kinds of
things developing over time the first
regular bank regulation occurred in 1863
in the United States because they
recognized that we if we're going to
have a national economy we need to have
a stable financial system so - at the
global level as we become work closely
integrated we have to have some rules we
have to have some regulations to make
that system work there are these global
public goods that I referred to not only
environmental public goods but go back
to the question why was the world
why was the IMF founded it was founded
after at the end of World War two
recognizing that there would be crises
and that would if one country has a
downturn it has an adverse effect on its
neighbors and therefore we all have a
stake in global economic stability and
therefore you need a multilateral
institution to promote economic
stability so the rationale for the
existence is very very strong and become
even stronger that's why my my response
is the issue isn't the abolition the
issue is really trying to reform it to
make go back to accomplishing its major
objective which is enhancing global
economic stability and helping those
countries facing an economic downturn
okay
countries are afraid negative effects of
globalization
well the question is is brought the
broad issue one aspect of the criticisms
of globalization is the adverse effect
on culture and that's a feeling the you
know folk as you say quite strongly in a
country like Franks let me first make a
general comment that globalization
doesn't necessarily have to have that
adverse effect in fact in some ways
globalization having some places has
facilitated the strengthening culture
just to give you a couple of examples
that the lowering of the communication
costs mean that you have global
communities of people who speak a
language that otherwise they would be
isolated they can come together in ways
that they can't they couldn't before
globalization occurred the that that
there are the kind of bringing together
people together can help preserve
cultures as well as destroy them the
second observation is that one needs
time for societies to adjust to change
and that this is a particular actual
cultures and in my mind one of the
important aspects of this is is is
regulating the pace of change pace of
the pace of change so that domestic
cultures can adapt to the changing and
and create a new culture that sort of
incorporates the old but also
incorporates the the changes that are
going on and that can often create a
stronger culture and this is where I
think a mistake that the IMF often makes
in that it pushes for a very rapid
change when one
a slightly slower change in the long run
would be even faster and we saw that in
a way in in Eastern Europe and the
former Soviet Union for the countries
that did it gradually have wound up
ahead it's sort of the race of the
turtle and the the race of a the hare
and the tortoise the tortoise is one in
many of the cases it's the countries
like Slovenia that what Dix reforms
slowly that are now ahead so I think
that's one one another aspect the third
thing is the World Bank has has actually
become very concerned about the broader
issue of culture and has been doing both
a research program and actually
supporting culture culture
partly because culture is part of the
glue that holds societies together and
one of the things that we're coming to
recognize is that economic success
depends on a certain degree of social
cohesion when you have societies you
know societies fraying apart violence is
one of the most adverse things for
economic growth and economic success and
so it is important to try to maintain
what's the term that economists uses
social capital and and culture is one of
the glues that helps maintain social
capital social khalif's in US and so the
World Bank is actually has a research
program that is focused on that that
issue in which mark Sisson who got the
Nobel Prize and for economic development
has played an important role okay I just
been told I have to stop yes okay